[Aplausos]
[Música]
argelia ha dicho adiós a sus días bajo
el gobierno del presidente abdelaziz
buteflika
[Aplausos]
han sido casi 20 los años que este
dirigente ha mandado sobre argelia
amigos los últimos tiempos han sido tan
extravagantes que habría que hacer un
crossover entre la ficción fantástica y
los mitos históricos para encontrar algo
igual por un lado estamos hablando de un
buteflika inválido e incapaz de
comunicarse que es simbólicamente
recuerda al decrépito rey y ceo del del
señor de los anillos' un gobernante en
manos de sus consejeros antes claro del
acelerado tratamiento antiedad que le
realiza gandalf
por otro lado hemos estado a punto de
ver algo así como una especie de versión
argelina del cid campeador un buteflika
absolutamente incapacitado al que sus
acólitos esperaban poder montar en una
silla de ruedas camino del quinto
mandato presidencial- un momento no
sabéis quién es el cid campeador
no no no no me refiero a este aunque a
veces lo parezca sino al personaje
legendario de la historia de españa' que
charlton heston interpretó en 1961 en la
película el cid
miércoles en londres
[Música]
black
os dejo en la descripción un link para
que podáis conocer
[Música]
el caso es que esto ya era demasiado y
los acontecimientos se precipitaron no
habrá quinto mandato de buteflika pero
amigos siendo honestos eso es lo de
menos pensar que en argelia y democracia
es como pensar que maduro ganó
limpiamente sus últimas elecciones pero
sentí una democracia sólida creo que es
la democracia más sólida más completa y
más libre de todo el continente
americano en argelia hay una democracia
nominal pero no una democracia efectiva
lo que sí hay son un montón de
interrogantes sobre la mesa que ha
supuesto buteflika para la historia de
argelia qué va a pasar ahora que
buteflika lo deja estamos a punto de
presenciar un nuevo capítulo de la
primavera árabe en visual político hoy
vamos a dar respuesta a todas estas
preguntas pero antes antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Música]
el origen
amigos no hace falta más que echar un
vistazo a la historia reciente de
argelia para comprender el enorme peso
que siempre ha tenido el ejército en
este país en los últimos 60 años argelia
ha vivido una guerra de liberación
contra los franceses una dictadura
militar durante más de dos décadas y una
guerra civil de 10 años dicho de otra
forma durante los últimos 60 años de una
forma u otra el ejército argelino ha
sido el protagonista principal de la
actualidad y la política nacional
de no haber sido por su repentina
dimisión el 27 de abril de 2019 se
hubieran cumplido 20 años desde que el
ejército entregó el poder a buteflika en
aquel momento buteflika estaba
considerado como el presidente de
consenso para argelia
[Música]
dos décadas después no son pocos quienes
ven este periodo como el de mayor
estabilidad para argelia que con los
años se ha convertido en uno de los
países más seguros del mundo árabe
sin embargo para muchos analistas más
que de estabilidad hay que hablar de
estancamiento pero un momento antes de
continuar creo que tenemos que responder
a una pregunta fundamental hoy en día
entre ses abdelaziz buteflika
[Música]
amigos nuestro protagonista nació hace
82 años en augusta una ciudad de
marruecos fronteriza con argelia sus
padres eran argelinos y con tan sólo 19
años se fue a pelear contra los
franceses con el ejército de liberación
nacional
durante la guerra su carrera fue
meteórica y entró a formar parte del
círculo de confianza del coronel agey
lume bien jefe del estado mayor de esta
forma una vez conseguida la
independencia del país en 1962 buteflika
con tan sólo 25 años ya era ministro y
al poco tiempo cuando el propio ume bien
entonces ministro de defensa dio un
golpe de estado dando paso a una
dictadura militar nuestro protagonista
en este vídeo jugó un papel clave fijaos
huari bumedien fue el presidente de
argelia hasta su muerte en 1978 junto a
él buteflika fue el ministro argelino de
exteriores durante todo el periodo de la
dictadura pero claro tras el
fallecimiento de bumedien pasó lo que
suele pasar a las personas que colaboran
o forman parte de una dictadura
buteflika cayó en desgracia fue acusado
y condenado por corrupción su imagen
pública quedó por los suelos y tuvo que
trasladarse a vivir a europa
eso sí no tardaría mucho en regresar a
una argelia con muchos pero que
muchísimos problemas en aquel momento y
estamos hablando de finales de los años
80 y principios de los 90 la república
argelina intentaba dejar atrás el
régimen del partido único y convertirse
de una vez por todas en una auténtica
democracia precisamente en ese contexto
en el año 1991 se celebraron las
primeras elecciones parlamentarias
libres en la primera vuelta a la
victoria del partido islamista fue
rotunda la segunda vuelta ya no tuvo
lugar el ejército anuló las votaciones
antes de que los islamistas lograran la
mayoría suficiente como para cambiar la
constitución y convertir a argelia en
una especie de nuevo irán entonces
argelia comenzó una guerra civil contra
el islamismo el saldo 200.000 muertos en
apenas una década
[Música]
[Aplausos]
le puso a
y amigos fue entonces en ese momento
tras la guerra civil cuando llegó la
hora de buteflika
en 1999 de forma inesperada el
presidente militar y amín zerual
renunció y convocó elecciones
presidenciales entonces el ejército que
no quería ni por asomo unas elecciones
libres vio en buteflika a la persona
indicada para llevar a argelia a la
reconciliación nacional
y efectivamente el gobierno de buteflika
supo acabar con la guerra civil podemos
decir que supo actuar con mano izquierda
en los peores momentos y no sólo eso
además buteflika vio la economía del
país a la inversión extranjera lo que
posibilitó que los ingresos del gas y el
petróleo estuvieran las políticas
sociales del gobierno
desde entonces amigos argelia se ha
convertido en una especie de país
rentista gran parte de la población se
acostumbró muy pero que muy pronto a los
subsidios ya que los productos básicos
estuvieran fuertemente subvencionados o
suena de algo todo ello le permitió a
buteflika mantener el apoyo popular sin
tener que dar un solo paso hacia la
democratización efectiva del país
[Aplausos]
desde la llegada al poder de buteflika
el poder se ha concentrado cada vez más
en el palacio presidencial hasta tal
punto que las instituciones políticas en
la práctica dejaron de tener valor
buteflika era el poder la concentración
de poder era tan grande que cuando en
2013 el líder sufrió un derrame cerebral
nadie supo ver una alternativa no había
un plan alternativo el plan el plan b el
cce el de todos pasaban por buteflika
como el líder político del país
el derrame amigos del lugar uno de los
escenarios más surrealistas que se han
visto en la política de un país
buteflika quedó postrado en una silla de
ruedas sin prácticamente capacidad de
hablar y completamente dependiente y
evidentemente en esas condiciones el
presidente estaba absolutamente
incapacitado para gobernar el país sin
embargo cuando en 2014 se celebran las
elecciones presidenciales nadie pensó en
un sustituto durante la campaña
electoral el presidente no pudo ni
siquiera dirigirse a la población pero a
pesar de ello tuvo una nueva victoria no
os extrañéis la democracia argelina es
así los resultados se determinan antes
de las votaciones así que el hecho de
que buteflika dieran un muy tiempo es
tampoco era tan importante ahora bien
claro la pregunta que muchos os estaréis
haciendo pero bueno vamos a ver enrique
si el viejo líder era incapaz de dar una
orden quien día antes ha mandado en
argelia amigos ahí es precisamente donde
entra en juego le pouvoir
fútbol es una palabra francesa qué
significa poder así que el poder o le
pudo como dicen en argelia es una
expresión para hacer referencia a las
élites que han dominado la república
argelina desde la independencia del país
unas élites políticas económicas y
militares que durante los últimos seis
años han sido capaces de consensuar un
nuevo presidente
bueno ya os podéis hacer una idea de
cómo funciona realmente la democracia
argelina y quién manda de verdad ahora
bien él no logran un candidato de
consenso no es algo que les preocupara
mucho a estas élites al fin y al cabo ya
tenían a buteflika para mantener sus
privilegios y el control sobre el país
sin embargo amigos
en esta ocasión cometieron un error de
cálculo atentos
[Música]
el límite
los que veis visual político lo sabéis
porque esto es algo que le ha ocurrido a
muchos países desde el año 2014 la caída
de los precios del petróleo y del gas
natural ha supuesto un duro golpe
también para la economía argelina los
ingresos del país disminuyeron un 50 un
50 por ciento y ojo no hay que olvidar
que más de la mitad del presupuesto de
argelia se financia con las
exportaciones de hidrocarburos por su
parte la balanza de pagos se ha
desequilibrado de tal manera que se
llegan a tomar medidas tan extremas como
estas
argelia prohíbe la importación de
teléfonos móviles muebles y alimentos
para frenar el déficit comercial y por
supuesto además de estas prohibiciones u
otros muchos bienes fueron gravados con
aranceles muy altos y es que claro
cuando un país rentista pierde su renta
pues como vas a pagar todas las compras
que haces con todas las rentas pues
simplemente no se puede llega la época
de los recortes los legisladores
argelinos aprueban el presupuesto que
establece aumentos en los precios del
combustible
con la caída de los precios del petróleo
y el gas la situación de argelia pasó a
ser crítica fijaos a pesar de que el
gobierno recortó el gasto un 10 por
ciento anual el déficit público alcanzó
la alarmante cifra del 12% del pib y
claro al no poder financiar muchas de
las subvenciones y los subsidios que el
gobierno repartía el coste de la vida se
ha disparado en los últimos cinco años
ahora creo que también podéis entender
el descontento social tan grande que hay
en argelia
argelia los altos precios de los
alimentos avivan el resentimiento
popular
por si esto fuera poco argelia de una
población muy pero que muy joven la edad
media del país está por debajo incluso
de los 30 años y amigos la combinación
de mucha gente joven y estancamiento
económico puede llegar a ser letal para
este tipo de regímenes porque pues
porque un país estancado en crisis no es
capaz de crear oportunidades para unos
jóvenes que tienen la fuerza y la
vitalidad como para echarse a las calles
y eso es precisamente lo que ha pasado
aquí para los jóvenes argelinos no había
más camino que lograr el fin del régimen
liderado por la momia que es como
popularmente se conoce a buteflika un
régimen dictatorial y corrupto muy
corrupto que ha condenado al país a un
estancamiento crónico en un país que se
ha tenido que acostumbrar a noticias
como esta carretera este-oeste 5.000
millones de dólares de corrupción
[Música]
de esta forma cuando el 10 de febrero de
2019 el régimen anunció la candidatura
de buteflika para un quinto mandato en
unas elecciones que por supuesto
estarían amañadas eso fue la gota que
colmó el vaso seis días más tarde el 16
de febrero de 2019 comenzaron las
movilizaciones contra esta candidatura y
contra este régimen poco a poco las
protestas se extendieron por todo el
país hablamos de las mayores
movilizaciones que argelia ha vivido
desde 1999
[Música]
el éxito ha sido increíble apenas seis
meses después de iniciarse las protestas
buteflika se ha visto obligado a
presentar su dimisión y a dejar el poder
claro que eso no significa que para
argelia los problemas se hayan terminado
está por ver que las élites acepten unas
elecciones libres sin pucherazos que la
oposición consiga organizarse y armar
una candidatura sólida y que realmente
el resultado de este proceso dé lugar a
una transición política efectiva
mientras tanto la economía del país
sigue teniendo muchos muchísimos
problemas para equilibrar el presupuesto
el país magrebí necesita un precio del
petróleo por encima de 99 dólares
actualmente se encuentra por debajo de
los 70
y no sólo eso veréis un reto que el país
tiene por delante es reducir su
dependencia de los hidrocarburos eso sí
es necesario pero antes que nada a
argelia tiene que liberalizar su
economía y favorecer la llegada de más
inversión extranjera en el propio sector
de los hidrocarburos para evitar que las
previsiones de producción se cumplan
fijaos
[Música]
amigos argelia es uno de los mayores
productores de energía en áfrica y un
proveedor clave de gas natural para toda
europa pero si no hay inversión la
producción caerá y evidentemente una
caída de la producción por culpa de no
haber invertido lo suficiente agravaría
seriamente los problemas económicos por
los que atraviesa el país
aquí en mi sol político ya hemos visto
que ha ocurrido por ejemplo en venezuela
por no realizar las inversiones que el
sector petrolero necesitaba es algo que
os contamos en este vídeo ahora bien
argelia no es venezuela eso es evidente
pero las empresas internacionales se
quejan de la enorme burocracia la enorme
incertidumbre y la enorme corrupción que
azota en el país en fin amigos como veis
el reto al canje les enfrenta en la
etapa post buteflika es enorme que
ocurrirá a partir de ahora logrará el
país la transición política y económica
que tanto necesita o por contra las
élites de la hera buteflika logrará
mantener su poder y control poniendo al
frente del país a otro presidente de su
confianza todo esto está por ver y desde
luego será algo que os con tenemos aquí
en visual político en cualquier caso
esperamos que ángeles se parezcan unos
años mucho más a túnez que a egipto en
fin amigos si os ha resulta interesante
este vídeo darle a like y no olvidéis
suscribirse a este canal para estar al
tanto de toda la actualidad
internacional un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]